inlassablement ont rempli des sacs de
sable à la chute et la fatigue commence
à se faire sentir
sean coupe 2 roues qu'on a en fait
chaque chapelle d'huin doubs n'a rien
d'une chute d'eau voici l'ampleur des
dégâts la montée subite du niveau de la
rivière du nord a pris bien des
résidents par surprise
l'eau a englouti une partie de la
municipalité
le canot est même devenu le moyen de
locomotion pour se rendre à l'école j a
atteint c'est la première fois que la
charmante à ses yeux des inondations un
peu d'eau jamais même à laval les
résidents s'inquiètent du niveau de
l'eau de la rivière des mille îles
surtout avec les précipitations de pluie
annoncée pour les prochaines heures
c'est ma nature que tout sens les make
way les communs il n'a pas le moral
on attend l'aide
pour protéger les résidences on ya
construit une digue de 750 m 24 ans
laura maes regard de catch au tableau
c'est parce qu'un à louiseville en
mauricie la crainte de tout perdre est
très présent on pourrait dire que c'est
toute notre histoire kinase une maison
qu'on peut perdre n'importe casse les
panneaux brise toutes les pentes marche
put en emparer nous en visons on va
affecter on regarde nos voisins et tout
le monde à vis de leurs aînés mais en
attendant la décrue le programme
gouvernemental pour déplacer les
riverains est très tentant j'ai
présentement des gens qui veulent s'en
aller
j'ai des copines touche en disant ils
sont ils sont enfermés dans leur maison
au tour de l'autre aux malades
alors ils m'ont dit monsieur le maire on
aimerait voir si vous me permettez on
est venu le voir mais je le good on veut
signer on va faire des ententes
on aimerait quitter immédiatement à
beauceville pour certains résidents
qu'ils commencent à nettoyer les dégâts
cette aide est plutôt bien accueillie
pensez-vous j'ai envie de passer là
dedans note fois une 2ème 3ème aucun
sens que nous donne la possibilité de
partir c'est extraordinaire
et puis le nouveau programme d aide aux
sinistrés devraient aussi alléger la
peine infligée par ces inondations
un programme qui sera beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup moins lourd qui nous
permettra je pense d'avoir des délais de
traitement des dossiers des réclamations
des sinistrés beaucoup moins lente
ainsi selon le niveau d'eau atteint dans
les maisons les sinistrés recevront une
indemnisation de 2340 dollar pour une
salle de bains 4095 dollars pour une
chambre un peu plus de 5000 $ pour un
salon et jusqu'à 6000 350 $ pour une
cuisine
en attendant et pour les prochains jours
les rivières reste plus que jamais sous
surveillance ici frédéric arnould radio
canada montréal